okay so this is earthen water Jason is
drinking what's left of his wife
if you don't recall she was juiced
juiced herself suicide very sad
cats almost like I can still hear her
laughing even now just right here
gasping snorting so charming how's Joey
anyway sushi tastes good
no I'm kind of nervous I'm guessing it's
kind of like pee you're juicing yourself
that means is that is that what she
normally tastes like pee no okay
she went to the toilet though I guess
that's true yeah so in loving memory
we'll put a little memorial thing right
there but anyway this is earthen water
and you notice that morning you're just
doing thereafter you know someone close
to you is God we got some of that in
this episode's I may be very happy
morning yes oh okay so actually I really
got a bit kind of a lot happened in this
episode trying to think like where
exactly I I know Finn was as we said
good morning that you know he couldn't
be with Flame Princess and so so
bubblegum comes across Flame Princess
who is like comes across well Flame
Princess comes across her I guess yes
and because she's analyzing her making
sure she doesn't explode pretty much and
destroy the kingdom and she says that
bubblegum says she can pretty much like
suppress her emotions with vents are
there so that you know no flame or
anything could happen it's pretty much a
reverse frozen you know Steph fire it's
it's cold or whatever and they're about
to do that and then bubblegum just in
the most obvious obvious joke you can
see coming just goes to cinnamon bun
it's like can you write down these
numbers can you not open that door I was
so hoping another joke was gonna happen
but it's just he does the opposite of
course and let's
they hang out at at his place while Finn
and Jake are fighting a legion of
Gunter's and their snowicon' strangers
and I get a great great little cameo by
the Ice King I'm gonna digging through
these Ice King cameos Ice King Gio's I
don't know so know why did Gunther why
is Gunther able because he has the crown
which I why I came took it off to
rebuild the place that it pretty much
his kingdom because Flame Princess
eradicated that's great continuity I
really love that they kept up with that
and so he's crashing and living at
Finn's plays like brushing his teeth and
Finn Qaeda has it going okay and then we
get a flashback showing literally from
birth lane princess's history she was
given virtue and this guy comes says
that the word is vampire part no oh you
stole breeched joke okay yeah all right
sorry pre when but but says that her
powers are going to be even greater than
the flame king so he's just like get rid
of her so the guy whether the messenger
tries to get rid of her and kinda can't
do it or does every he gets the two the
one guy who can hold her he was gonna he
was gonna like basically let her walk
off a cliff and he couldn't do it so
he's going to give her two and he's like
yeah and then she starts just she's a
baby so she just starts blowing stuff up
and bubblegum comes sir picks her up in
this flame suit tells the flame king hey
keep her under control this is not cool
come on beat something of a parent so
that's like what are you talking about I
didn't lose anything I love that look
bubblegum gives to the little yeah like
that was just great it was so strange I
love it um so so he puts her in a big
Lantern thing so now we know the origin
of that flame princess is really pissed
off and says I'm gonna go and change
things so she goes to the fire Kingdom
and pretty much just
it over now puts the father in the lamp
the whatever that is and if Finn and
bubblegum find her and they come in
she's sort of a kick-ass suit that was
that just looked awesome
yeah and now she's the ruler of the
flame Kingdom and they pretty much make
up and she says you know everyone has to
be honest here I mean like everything
has to be totally 100% honest can you be
totally wanted reprints % honest with me
and he goes and that's about it um I
don't know what to make about mmmm at
the end I don't know if that's like a
joker if that's gonna lead to something
else but yeah we definitely have kind of
like a same before you know accounting
for sort of the you know the lack of
mourning of the lack of Santa's day we
didn't see the episode before which I'm
glad they did dress I'm glad they got to
that it wasn't like he just met up with
her it's like hey let's go steady again
you know it's like you show him feeling
really bad so it's at least I got it
there like I said I think there was a
little backwards but well I love the
fact that he's like so we're cool right
she's like yeah he's like so we're
dating again
she's like new well does she actually
say no I thought that she said new I
thought she said if you can be totally
honest no no no okay I mistaken yes he
can come and hang out with her as long
as he's totally honest okay yeah okay I
missed that part I thought they said
their back to you no no sorry I was too
blown away by cinnamon buns stupidity
speaking of grating characters from
Lemongrab does you know what I was
hoping you know what I was hoping when
she says now can you just do this one
thing and Mark these letters to a mark
these numbers down and not open that
door I was hoping he would just do it
and be a total surprise
like you just follow through with it but
then when you see the door open up it's
like everyone saw that coming and then
yeah I don't know I'm getting kind of
sick of that character callek would what
you said my favorite reaction I
characterize it again is Bree in was it
like two episodes ago when Marceline
takes bubblegum away and just semen bunk
ups I just goes I am free just goes cat
damnit it's kind of summing up my
feelings towards I care it's just so
dumb um but if you like I get it I
drives me nuts oh but okay so the seem
very much like a it may be a little too
crowded the more I'm thinking about it
cuz I'm thinking like God to start off
with thin feeling bad and then the ice
king and then the Flame Princess
and that bubblegum comes in and then I
gasp to take the powers away and then
she gets with cinnamon bun and then are
going to the flame Kingdom then we get
word from her background or a background
first and then she's taking over the
flame came it's like got what frigging
what happens in this episode um and I
guess they're not going together now I
like them as a cowboy I hope they keep
trying
I hope they work out something with that
um but it was still falling I like
seeing some things you know can't
wrapped up there
anything with that fire kingdom I love I
love it even the messenger look great
the freaking messenger was a great
design keep David as the fire king is
still hilarious people can't forget he
can he can do comedy pretty well because
you got the father in uh there's
something about Mary and he's like
you've never seen that I saw yours ago
he was the views that isn't the beans of
the frame you know he's that guy in the
very opening he's Cameron Diaz's father
in it and it's hilarious I mean he's so
funny and people forget that he can do
comedy really well and I think because
he does have that very deep kind of
menacing voice it sounds so much funnier
what he's like you know I'm gonna ground
you for reals you know it just sounds so
funny
oh wait Cameron Diaz is dead
um there's something about Mary okay no
hold on this is Keith David right yes
Cameron Diaz his father was black in the
movie yeah really yeah I don't remember
that ya know anything I'm like it's her
different Keith David that I'm getting
this wrong no days he is
he shapes like hugely funny and I think
he's one of the best things in it
I'll have to read what yeah I want is
worth it just for like okay it doesn't
fully hold up but it's worth it just
right yeah because he's just a liar he
okay um but yes I like to find likes it
wrapped up a few things i I want to see
them as a couple but but maybe not as
much as Allah see her rule the kingdom
because of that seemed kind of cool and
that can be kind of fun and what I like
to see I like to see the honesty things
start to backtrack like having every
single person be honest starts to work
against the man stay you know because
there's some things that should be kept
a secret some things that shouldn't be
said and like they're sitting there it's
like I'm just on edge because you know
I'm secretly dating his sister yeah then
the guards just like yeah yeah yeah and
that was hugely funny those guards were
hugely funny oh yeah something about
guards and security men is that like
they really crack them very so yeah I
wouldn't mind seeing that like maybe
fall fury or something but yeah no sorry
I think our rule the kingdom white
that's kind of fun I think that's kind
of cool um yeah where your thoughts I
liked it I like that Finn got the
beatdown of his life in a sense this
entire episode he is consistently
reminded how he screwed things up with
with Ice King and
Flame Princess Peebles everyone's just
kind of reminding him how much he
screwed up and I think that's something
that Finn needs he needs to know that
yeah he screwed up it's his fault no one
else's fault
it's his fault and I liked that I mean I
like Finn Finn it's probably my favorite
character honestly but sometimes you
just need to hear the honest-to-god
truth and yeah I liked that I did love
when Jake hid behind the cushion
yeah that was funny I like how he's
getting confused like what a boys
hanging out it's like you know we can we
can do each other's nails until start
nah that's not boys man up oh we can go
shopping and get new hats i my problem
was cinnamon bun and it's a lot of shows
is that mentally retarded characters if
that is what he is I mean it well he's a
big I I sort of wonder that's it I was
kind of getting that vibe too I was
already there going that direction but
there's too many characters where
they're just overly stupid and they make
the stupidest mistakes and it's like yes
it's people's fault for consistently
putting cinnamon bun in these places of
power or control or whatever she's dumb
for letting him do this but at the same
time that doesn't excuse him of what
he's done and it's like I can't stand
then putting the dumb character in these
situations just so he can screw things
up but in the end he's actually the good
guy cuz look he's watching out for Flame
Princess know he's got his own donkey so
I can't but he broke the rules well I
was gonna say what I mean that they
tried to give him a little bit of a
connection with a flame princess which I
think my first thought is please don't I
don't want to see more of this character
I'm just sick of them on the other hand
if they don't I mean yeah I think you
can still make the argument I mean if
they are going for it you know there's
something you know I'm mentally off
about or something like that uh it's
like hugely disrespectful and
mean-spirited yeah because all they're
doing like you said they're just having
him come in and screw things up and well
back in the beginning one thing I loved
was cinnamon bun was there he was kind
of like happy-go-lucky a little bit
nutty a little bit half-witted like with
the of the tarts hmm and years ago
she'll go dude do and it was kind of
like a little bit more genuine and cute
and nice I felt loved it yeah now it's
just kind of like oh look at the frickin
moron yeah you screw everything up it
feels very me
I mean you know like I said they do have
this heartfelt kind of heartfelt thing
where you know her and him kind of
connect which I'm not against I'm
actually not against you know her can I
be one who is so simple that's like he
almost can't lie because he just doesn't
know much else yeah you know it's like
all he knows is the truth and what's
told to him so if there's a part of you
that can't respects it but yeah I'm
count with you it's most of the time
he's only there to screw things up and
it seems like it's written out of this
very you know we're trying to be more
funny you know so we can be we're trying
to be mean to be funny
not you know like hey isn't this a
likeable character you know isn't kind
of fun when he screws up because he's so
likeable it's like no it's just it's
just mistake upon mistake and not much
character and so you just really start
to dislike him yeah and I feel like we
don't get to know him that well or like
you said early on it was just kind of a
fun like you said just everything was
gonna happy and go-lucky it's like you
know cool like if you told me he had
something you know it mentally not all
there it's like that's fine cuz he you
know he still likable and he's still fun
and you know and the it's like I
wouldn't my hand with this guy cuz he's
you know just so it's so much fun but
yeah then he just gets so stupid and and
so not catching on to anything and only
put in there just to screw things up I
mean there's also one time uh tree
trunks and mr. pig where they fell in
love and all that stuff there's other
episode like it seems like cinnamon bun
is there to fill the void for any
character they kind of need at the time
this one they needed it kind of a dumb
moron a character cinnamon bun there's
the one tree trunks and mr. pig where
they're making out at the concert when
people says like cinnamon bun it's over
tell everyone to go home and Cinnabons
kind of an ass he's kind of like just
like everyone way you know it's like
okay they need someone to be loud and
obnoxious well he's simple it's okay he
can do any louder but at the same time
no he's kind of a jerk like he's kind of
there to fill the void for any emotion
they need some loving character sure a
dopey character sure a nagger character
sure someone that you don't get much of
a character yeah yes or whatever
emotions
neither for the moment and I'd love to
actually hear and see cinnamon cinnamon
buns past that would be kind of mean I'd
be curious where he came from and how he
got to where he is but at the same time
it's just kind of like me I don't know
if I want to really invest that well I
guess I don't want to put up with him
for it you know Olivia I would like if
they bring backs or we use it more the
very light-hearted fun you know
enjoyable where we like being around him
and not oh he's just gonna screw things
up yeah okay like it's okay if I care
didn't make mistakes as crew if you
think's up it's like that's all he's
become yeah you know he's he's a
nuisance that's what he's being right
he's always being written as a nuisance
except for you know a little bit waste
I'm the flame princess even though
that's by accident yeah you know it sort
of seems like so did someone that the
flame princess could talk to that they
could actually she will when she went
back to the flame Kingdom now she has a
companion that she can talk to most of
the other cast they couldn't really just
simplistically say oh let's get rid of
that person or let's move them to this
kingdom because peppermint Butler or
whatnot it would just be really weird
cinnamon but it kind of works we can
actually remove him and it'll be okay
everything will still flow like
clockwork but if we need him we can
always kind of bring him back yeah and
like I said I'm not against them having
a connection especially with him being
so simple yeah it's the more like you
said that he's written more as a
nuisance than the one other thing now
serve never really dawn on me until is
watching this episode uh and I'm not a
guest if I'm just noticing more and more
it's like wow this was like a really
common thing and maybe it's at romain
I'm sure they've listed somewhere uh is
that a lot of a lot of stories where
some usually I try to think of any
occurrence where there's a male but
where there's a female that has like
some sort of power they can you know
blow something up or do whatever it's
almost always linked to the emotions you
know I'm thinking this and when I
product frozen before that's science you
can do when she gets angry or yeah very
emotional whatever cheap turns things
are there's no
I tried friggin the Princess Peach game
that's what she fights way she fights
with like her emotions and crying and
stuff like that and it's one of those
things where I'm thinking to myself you
know like it's it's fine if someone
wants to like I like the idea of the
emotions being connected to the person
you know Acuras or work that way to
which I thought was really cool but I'm
thinking uh-huh you know so I care which
cure no I'm Kira but the I know but
there was no character that was alive in
the movie Akira or anything in Tetsuo
now yeah in the movie Akira okay maybe I
said that wrong sorry yes oh yeah cuz
you said that it might put a cure it's
not really in the movie only briefly
it's Tetsuo yeah I know it's at smokers
yeah
okay um but I'll try think it's like
outside of that it's like I haven't
really seen that that much and it's like
it's not a bad idea cuz it's like it's
you know everything that dramas about
emotions and it copies about emotions
everything so having a visual
representation literally be crazy and
huge you know it's like that's fine but
it seems to always be you know like
either a girl or young woman you know
who's going through like adolescence or
something or going through you know
growing up and it's like you know it
calm down your emotions calm down your
emotions I'm always like I'm just
starting to get tired of this trope I
think I'm just seeing if one too many
times um which I say it's worked fine
you know for the most part you know like
I said it I love Flame Princess I don't
see adolescent boys go through it week
we kind of have with you know with
Tetsuo and stuff but it no it's not even
that it's just more that it's like you
know yes it seems to be more with women
but it's like whatever it's more just
the trope in general of seeing these you
know the emotions fuel them whatever
thing I'm just starting to get a little
tired of it you know it's like it it
worked great but let's move on to
something else you know I think I'm
finally starting to get a little tired
but you know it's it's fine just as long
as we like stop when we know it's like
okay we've done this to death let's
let's move on
ALMS never gonna happen dude
well I think do you watch Dragon Ball Z
yeah do they do the same thing like are
their powers connected to their motion
every time they scream something
explodes oh you just serve maybe
assumption it's I mean yes and no you
can argue that yes it is definitely in
connected to their emotions
Goku went super saiyan for the first
time upon the death of his friend but I
mean that's kind of different than just
getting pissed off his friend died right
in front of them so he flip stuff you
know hello
I mean yes you know honestly it's okay
until you talk to honestly I mean it's
like I said it makes sense because
there's nothing that looks cooler than a
character yeah I got some sort of visual
representation of like an explosion or
things things sharp everything freezing
you know some circle awesome well
normally when they go it's they're
building up their power I'm not actually
pissed anyway yeah that could be they're
just going oh they're just kind of
building up their power that's it well I
think that's why some it you know like
this trope is catching on because it's
like well now whatever they do that
something cool will happen it's not just
they have to be angry or like somebody
has to die or something you know and
they have to react it's whenever they're
angry we can have something cool happy
yeah you know that creates drama because
the more you know angry or upset they
get the more stuff will get crazy and
that makes things more traumatic bla bla
bla um like it like if it I'm just I'm
just trying to get more bored by it but
I need the old x-men comics that love
the old x-men comics it um you won't
have any of that in there well I know
everyone just has powers cuz they're
just awesome Vanitas so can't
wait for apocalypse no yes no okay
the only reason to get through x-men
Days of Future past is to get to
apocalypse why because I was the
apocalypse what a different building uh
I'd be fine with sinister running mr.
sinister yes a lot mr. sinister he's
back
no yes I haven't heard of mr. sinister
since the inferno saga yeah but he was
cool he had the cool
like the black and the beard spidery
thing it was cool that or apocalypse I'm
cool with you okay only if apocalypse
takes angel inter okay having not seen
Days of Future past was angel in it
no oh dumb see the only way I want to
see apocalypse is if he's actually
making the four horsemen and he takes
angel returns me he was some three they
could bring him back a couple mutants I
did that back yeah I'll be angel I'm at
the movie by a more fit appearance of a
rhino